[Music]
reed is with us reid is in san antonio
texas hi reed how are you
howdy dave hey ken thanks for taking my
call i'm glad to be on the show sure
what's up
hey yeah so my wife and i got married
about nine months ago really excited and
we are thinking of buying a house and we
are adamant
about not having any sort of credit card
or credit score now how do we do that
okay you just have to have a mortgage
company that does what's called manual
underwriting
like churchill mortgage that's sponsored
us here for
uh almost 30 years here on the ramsey
show they do manual underwriting manual
underwriting is what they used to do
before there was a fico score like when
i first got in the real estate business
okay right and that simply means that
they
in the old days now we wouldn't do it
exactly this way today but in the old
days we would mail the mortgage company
would mail
a vod
request to your bank a verification of
deposit to see if you have money in the
account to do your down payment they
would send a voe
to your employer a verification of
employment your employer would write
down and say yes he works here and
here's what he makes send it back to the
mortgage company that was all snail mail
in the old days right
and um but they actually went around and
then they they checked with your
landlord and they looked at your credit
bureau report and saw what was actually
on the credit bureau report what was
being paid were you paying the bills
that you have on time and if you don't
have any bills on the credit bureau
report they assumed you were smart
um because you are uh and instead of
dumb not like the fico score says you're
dumb if you don't have any bills uh
because it's only a measure of how much
you play kissy face with the bank
so um
the uh but that's how that's what manual
underwriting is it means they manually
actually have to verify that the human
being is capable of paying the note
and then you can get the mortgage and
it's the same exact rate
no no more no less than a regular fico
score rate the difference is if you've
got a you know a
750 fico score a monkey can make that
loan they just look at the number and go
big number do it okay then there's
absolutely zero analysis
okay other than they depend on the
analysis that was created that created
the fico score to be their analysis
which is part of what caused the crash
in 2008 because we were loaning people
with high fico scores money who were
actually broke
and so we had a whole bunch of broke
people buying houses and it caused the
2008 crash that's not happening as much
now
but one thing fico has gone in and
worked on their algorithm because it
sucks
but um it's mathematically impalable but
anyway all that side issue from model
soapbox but yeah you can get a mortgage
just go to a mortgage company that
you know that does manual underwrite